INVESTIGATORS TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WHY A GAPING HOLE BLEW OPEN
ON AN ALASKA AIRLINES FLIGHT
FROM PORTLAND.
THE NTSB SAYS A CRUCIAL PIECE OF
THE 737 MAX JET, THE DOOR PLUG
HAS BEEN FOUND IN SOMEBODY'S
BACKYARD.
>> TAKE LOOK AT THESE NEW IMAGES
FROM INVESTIGATORS.
WHAT YOU ARE SEEING THERE IS
SEAT CUSHIONS AND HEADRESTS
RIPPED OFF BY THE EXPLOSIVE
FORCE OF THE DEPRESSURIZATION IN
THE CABIN.
THE WARNING LIGHT PREVIOUSLY
WENT OFF ON THE SAME PLANE
MULTIPLE TIMES INCLUDING THE DAY
BEFORE THE HORRIFYING FLIGHT.
ALASKA AIRLINES HAS RESTRICTED
THEM FROM FLYING THAT PLANE ON
BIG FLIGHTS, LIKE, LONG ONES TO
HAWAII FOR EXAMPLE, OVER THE
OCEAN IN CASE THEY HAVE TO
QUICKLY LAND.
LISTEN TO THIS PASSENGER TO
DESCRIBE THE MOMENT THE DOOR
PLUG BLEW OUT.
>> YOU HEARD A BIG, LOUD BANG TO
THE LEFT REAR, LIKE, IN ROW 20,
AND A WHOOSHING SOUND AND ALL
THE OXYGEN MASKS DEPLOYED.
YOU COULD SEE LATER THERE WAS A
TWO-WINDOW SECTION THAT BLEW UP,
AND A BOY AND HIS MOTHER WERE
SITTING IN THE ROW.
HIS SHIRT WAS SUCKED OFF AND
WENT OUT OF THE PLANE.
HIS MOTHER WAS HOLDING ONTO HIM.
>> JOINING US NOW IS THE WOMAN
IN CHARGE OF THIS INVESTIGATION,
JENNIFER HOMINY.
SHE WAS ABLE TO INSPECT THE
PLANE, ACTUALLY WALK THROUGH IT.
SO SHE HAS A LOT OF INFORMATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
WITH US.
LET'S BEGIN WITH WHAT YOU SAW
THAT WE DON'T KNOW MORE ABOUT
WHEN YOU WALKED THROUGH THAT
PLANE.
WHAT DO PEOPLE HAVE TO KNOW THIS
MORNING?
>> YEAH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR HAVING
ME, POPPY.
AND IT WAS DESCRIBED TO US BY
THE FLIGHT CREW THAT IT WAS A
VERY VIOLENT, EXPLOSIVE EVENT
WHEN IT OCCURRED, AND YOU CAN
SEE THAT FROM INSIDE THE
AIRCRAFT.
NOW WE WERE ABLE TO INSPECT THE
AIRFRAME ITSELF FROM THE
EXTERIOR AND FOUND ABSOLUTELY NO
STRUCTURAL DAMAGE TO THE
AIRPLANE SO THAT'S A GREAT
THING.
INSIDE THERE WAS A LOT OF DAMAGE
TO NONCRITICAL COMPONENTS.
EVERYTHING FROM PANELING TO TRIM
TO INSULATION COMING OUT OF THE
PANELING.
SOME SEPARATION OF THE PLASTIC
INSIDE OF THE WINDOWS, ALTHOUGH
THE SEAL AND THE GLASS WINDOWS
THEMSELVES WERE STILL INTACT,
AND THEN OF COURSE, YOU HAVE THE
TORQUING OF SOME OF THE SEATS IN
THOSE ROWS.
SO IT MUST HAVE BEEN TRULY
TERRIFYING.
>> IT'S THE SIZE OF A
REFRIGERATOR, THE HOLE IN THE
PLANE WHILE YOU'RE IN THE AIR
GOING 400 MILES AN HOUR.
IT'S TECHNICALLY CALLED THE DOOR
PLUG, BUT THAT'S THE DOOR.
I MEAN, THE DOOR BLEW OFF FOR
INTENTS AND PURPOSES.
I WONDER, NOW THAT THEY HAVE
FOUND IT, WHAT WILL THAT TELL
YOU ABOUT IF THIS COULD HAPPEN
ON OTHER PLANES?
>> YEAH, AND JUST TO CLARIFY,
THIS IS NOT AN OPERATIONAL DOOR
INSIDE THE AIRCRAFT.
>> RIGHT.
>> PASSENGERS WOULD ONLY SEE THE
PANELING OUTSIDE.
YOU WOULD SEE WHAT LOOKS LIKE A
DOOR, THE PLUG IN THE AIRCRAFT
ITSELF, BUT FROM THE TIME WE GOT
HERE, WE BEGAN DOCUMENTING THE
SCENE AND LOOKING AT HOW THE
AIRFRAME IS SITUATED RIGHT NOW,
LOOKING AT EVERYTHING FROM
WITNESS MARKS AND PAINT TRANSFER
ON DIFFERENT COMPONENTS TO TRY
TO BEGIN ANALYZING WHAT
OCCURRED.
OUR FOCUS RIGHT NOW IS ON THIS
AIRCRAFT TO DETERMINE WHAT
HAPPENED, HOW IT HAPPENED, AND
TO PREVENT IT FROM HAPPENING
AGAIN, AND ONCE WE DETERMINE
THAT, WE CAN SEE IF THERE'S A
GREATER CONCERN THAT WE WANT TO
ISSUE AN URGENT SAFETY
RECOMMENDATION FOR.
>> SO TALKING ABOUT SOME
POTENTIAL WARNINGS THAT THIS
COULD HAPPEN, DECEMBER 7th AND
THEN AGAIN ON JANUARY 3rd AND
JANUARY 4th, THE
DEPRESSURIZATION WARNING LIGHT
ON THIS PLANE CAME ON, AND THEN
IT WAS INSPECTED AND RESET, AND
THEN THIS PLANE WAS BACK IN THE
AIR, BUT WITH CONDITIONS, RIGHT?
IT COULDN'T DO LONG-HAUL FLIGHTS
OVER THE OCEAN LIKE TO HAWAII IN
CASE IT HAD TO LAND.
AFTER THOSE THREE WARNINGS,
SHOULD THIS PLANE HAVE EVER BEEN
IN THE AIR?
>> THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION
BECAUSE THAT IS WHAT WE ARE
LOOKING AT WITH ALASKA RIGHT
NOW, AND WITH BOEING RIGHT NOW,
THAT ALERT, THAT ILLUMINATED
THOSE THREE TIMES CERTAINLY IS
VERY DISCONCERTING TO OUR
INVESTIGATORS AND WE WANT TO
LOOK AT THAT, BUT IT MAY HAVE
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING TO DO WITH
WHAT OCCURRED IN THE CABIN OF
THE AIRCRAFT ON THAT -- DURING
THAT EVENT.
IT DID ILLUMINATE THE FLIGHT
CREW.
THEY HAD SWITCHED TO A DIFFERENT
MODE BECAUSE THERE WAS A BACKUP
SYSTEM, AND ONCE THEY LANDED, IT
WAS TESTED, INSPECTED, RESET,
AND PUT BACK IN SERVICE, BUT AS
YOU SAID, ALASKA AIR TOOK SOME
PRECAUTIONS TO PUT SOME
RESTRICTIONS ON WHERE THAT COULD
FLY, AND THAT'S SOMETHING
WE'RE -- OUR SYSTEMS CREW IS
LOOKING INTO.
>> BUT IF THERE'S A PRECAUTION
ON WHERE A PLANE CAN FLY, SHOULD
THAT PLANE BE FLYING ANYWHERE?
>> AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT.
ALASKA AIR TELLS US THE REASON
THAT WAS PUT IN PLACE IS TO THAT
THEY COULD GET TO AN AIRPORT IF
THE LIGHT ILLUMINATED AND COULD
GET REPAIRS AGAIN, BUT IT IS
SOMETHING THAT IS A CONCERN FOR
US, SO WE'RE GOING TO LOOK, BUT
AGAIN, I WOULD JUST CAUTION IT
MAY HAVE ABSOLUTELY NOTHING TO
DO WITH WHAT OCCURRED ON THAT
DAY.
>> NO, FAIR, AND I'M GLAD YOU
POINT THAT OUT AGAIN.
I WAS FLYING HOME LAST NIGHT
WITH OUR TWO LITTLE KIDS RIGHT
BEHIND, YOU KNOW, THE SAME AREA
AS THIS PLANE, A DIFFERENT
PLANE, BUT STILL, IT'S ALL I
COULD THINK ABOUT.
SO MY QUESTION THIS MORNING IS,
IS IT SAFE FOR ANYONE TO FLY ON
THESE BOEING MAX JETS RIGHT NOW?
>> IT'S -- OUR AVIATION SYSTEM
IS THE SAFEST IN THE WORLD.
WE ARE THE GOLD STANDARD FOR
SAFETY IN OUR AIR SPACE, BUT WE
NEED TO MAINTAIN THAT, AND WHEN
AN EVENT OCCURS LIKE THIS, IT IS
UP TO US TO TAKE A CLOSE LOOK AT
WHAT HAPPENED TO MAKE SURE WE
MAINTAIN SAFETY IN THE AIR.
FOR THIS ONE, I WILL MENTION
WE'RE DISAPPOINTED THAT THE
COCKPIT VOICE RECORDER WAS
OVERWRITTEN.
WE CAN LEARN A LOT FROM THAT
COCKPIT VOICE RECORDER.
WE HAVE URGED THE FAA TO EXTEND
THE COCKPIT VOICE RECORDER TIME
FROM 2 HOURS TO 25 HOURS BECAUSE
WE WANT TO HEAR COMMUNICATIONS,
NOISE, ALERTS ON THE FLIGHT DECK
WHICH MAY HELP US PREVENT FUTURE
TRAGEDIES.
>> JUST SO PEOPLE UNDERSTAND,
THAT IS WHAT SORT OF
AUTOMATICALLY HAPPENS ON SOME OF
THESE PLANES THAT AREN'T THE
NEWEST.
IS IT EVERY TWO HOURS IT SORT OF
RESETS AND YOU WANT THAT TO BE
EXTENDED MUCH LONGER SO YOU CAN
ALWAYS HEAR IN A SITUATION JUST
LIKE THIS?
JUST FINALLY WITH BOEING, THERE
HAVE BEEN A NUMBER OF ISSUES
WITH THE BOEING MAX LINE.
BOTH OF THOSE CRASHES WERE
CAUSED IN PART BECAUSE OF THE
M-CAST SYSTEM WHICH THEY'VE
CHANGED, BUT IS THERE AN ISSUE
AT BOEING REGARDING SAFETY?
>> YEAH.
WE'LL HAVE TO SEE THAT THROUGH
THE COURSE OF OUR INVESTIGATION.
IN THE PAST WHEN WE'VE
INVESTIGATED, SAY MALFUNCTION ON
A PLANE JUST ABOUT A YEAR AGO,
WE FOUND THAT WE NEEDED TO GO
BROADER AND LOOK AT REPAIRS FOR
ALL OF THE FLEET.
WE'LL -- WE MAY LOOK AT THE
MANUFACTURER, THE DESIGN OF THIS
AIRCRAFT, BUT WE GO WHERE THE
EVIDENCE TAKES US.
>> WE REALLY APPRECIATE ALL OF
THIS INFORMATION THIS MORNING,
JENNIFER.
THANKS TO YOUR TEAM AND COME
BACK AS YOU HAVE MORE
INFORMATION.